[Music]
in town is everywhere news submitted by
clans of fans a singing homeless woman
was offered a recording contract after
going viral oh is it the lady in
Koreatown the opera one Cape Town the
opera singer her name you know her Lily
yeah she's been viral
have you seen her life no but I think a
cop recorded her exactly so this is
Emily here
she has been homeless for a few years
why she's such a fashionable homeless
that's a great photo
it's like a [ __ ] Versace a drink it's
like the next Chanel 4 she reminds me of
like those damn she's good-looking
yeah I like those old models you know
how like you're like you have you look
like you're still like 20 spirited but
you look like 80 and [ __ ] like how does
that even happen
no like have you have you seen those
like old fashionable ladies that are
like I don't know any specific names but
then they'll be photo shoots of them and
you just like you you in capture the
spirit of like a young person is it like
Cate Blanchett like borderline like then
are we talking about like Helen Mirren
Helen Mirren's [ __ ] hot right like
older Bo's Helen Mirren Helen Mirren's
my I got a Hall Pass oh really yeah good
Nikki yeah Nikki superbosses on your
noisy hobby shop she's it Nikki gave him
ten options he chose one are chosen as
your loyal what are the other options
there's no I just want interesting all
right so LAPD headquarters tweeted out a
video of her singing in the subway which
some of you guys have seen they
captioned it four million people call LA
home four million stories four million
voices sometimes you just have to stop
and listen to one to hear something
beautiful
damn dude that's some LAPD like
marketing right there yeah I don't know
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
got the strongest arms in the world
that's like 10 bags she doesn't hold it
though no she has to
I see it's pretty much sushi drops you
can't say she did a full an hour concert
what's happening she's so clean for a
homeless person I know and I thought
she'd be on my [ __ ] sucker and [ __ ]
because I don't like homeless people man
maybe we're at [ __ ] Santa Monica
yesterday and in this dude had his light
little blanket out and he was just
chilling on the beach and then he was
like [ __ ] stuck a [ __ ] [ __ ] a
[ __ ] I don't make enough money for you
to [ __ ] spill on my cocaine
everywhere and he was having an argument
like with his imaginary wife yeah yeah
it was it was because he was like you
[ __ ] [ __ ] yeah sure that's why no
confused or he was yelling at her like
like he's like you well he didn't say
suck a [ __ ] what he actually said was
the n-word [ __ ] yeah can you can you do
that one
I want to know the real story and then
he was like and he was like I don't make
enough money for you to spill all my
cocaine everywhere and he's like stop
giving me the heroin and everyone like
holy [ __ ]
and it he's like I don't find a heroin
that much not that much denial what if
he got a record contract to make a rap
album dude crazy not that much or insult
common contract he roasted his wife
pretty good huh
n-word [ __ ] that's pretty good yeah
it's an original yeah good even a pimp
but in Joe's mind he's a married man
yeah and he was like he was like I don't
make enough money we're gonna spin okay
to everywhere and he was looking for it
on the floor and [ __ ] and I was like
damn dude then that sounds like it's
been a real place like 10 like you or
someone that would just throw his
cocaine everywhere he also could have
been on Bluetooth and he could have had
cocaine in front of him you know he was
just a surfer guy was just dirty a
little dirty wasn't homeless dude
he you know he looked like he could have
been like a dirty surfer like just with
the beanie Monica yeah we went to Santa
Monica recently we saw this this older
woman who looked like a really rich
housewife that went out for like a jog
because she was wearing like athletic
clothes and stuff um but she was talking
to herself as she was staring in the in
the windows of the homes near there like
white appear or not appear but the
boardwalk and I was telling Casey like
dude
is she to share like a Bluetooth in your
ear or something but I kept staring at
her like she has nothing in her ear
she's not talking to anyone she just
like this is her time to go crazy in
public like that's how I kind of read
eight where I was like damn I wonder
what kind of [ __ ] she goes through in
life where she has to come out here and
like yell at herself from the reflection
of the windows I was there at one
morning and then dozes bombed I was like
hey [ __ ] you and he goes to another
group hey [ __ ] you and then everyone's
like why are you telling me [ __ ] you
goes that's how I say good morning
[ __ ] you too then he's like [ __ ] you no
relief for me scream [ __ ] yeah but in a
positive way okay cuz me you know we're
out there to like do some like training
in the morning and I thought you guys
were homeless he could get a contract as
a Walmart beer that's true oh boy oh
yeah nice too excited to go to school in
Westwood and there's a ton of homeless
people and I came out of a class which
is in like a satellite office at night
and I walk out and the same thing that
comes up to me goes back you know I'm
like what and sorry I walk I took a few
more steps at that time to someone else
it was no [ __ ] you and I'm like Mean
Girls yeah you white boy guys crazy
he's so [ __ ] up he thought you're a
white boy yeah not privileged for a
little bit
[Laughter]
so she's 52 years old she's what she
looks so good I need to get on that
homeless guy she looked 45 52 she looks
up there she looks at okay she looks
early felt we'll see her she's at least
10 years younger well in that shot
that's a [ __ ] that's been done
something's happened I thought she was
60 to be honest like her specifically
for this angle she look good yeah that's
how I compliment my mom too but anyway
so she she came to the US when she was
24 years old oh she's not American from
Russia yeah dad's or she was trained you
used to teach lessons she's a trained
violinist and pianist see this this goes
to show classical music just does not
pay the bill
no no so then she ended up until later
in life true so she would be playing the
violin on the street after she suffered
from serious
issues and she wasn't able to pay for
her rent or pay for her health bills so
then eventually her violin got stolen
which was worth $10,000
Oh No so then she couldn't even make any
sort of living anymore and that's what
led her to be very coolest I wonder if
that was the case or she went a little
off and and and [ __ ] people over and
then like all this stuff or whatever
just like you know her head wasn't right
and then she just couldn't keep it
together I don't know what she is I'm
saying like this is a quote for her I
have people that feel sorry for me but I
don't want to be a burden to anybody
$10,000 violin the violin industry needs
a chill dude what the [ __ ] that's not on
the Sheep pen yeah why does it cost ten
grand
it's a piece of wood what you need you
need wood yeah you need wood from a
specific tree that grows in a specific
climate yeah and the older it is the
warmer that some of them only 200 pounds
like the million dollar ones the
Stradivarius like ten G's is a cheap
violin Jesus pretty into violence and
you eat a horse
yeah for the bow seat but they're
everywhere now a few well the one that
Bart's talking about they can go out for
like a milk a million or more each Wow
and those were from a special era and we
had a like a like a quick Ice Age during
that time so the way the trees grew
during that time they're not gonna grow
like that ever again for like another
come on man really yeah seriously
[ __ ] Kirkland violin we can get this
chick probably that's oh you mean like
for this girl how could you tell man
like the other day it's Paul's can tell
[ __ ] whales in the water can hear it
going oh it's what I did the blowhole
that's when they know it yeah they could
hear the way it could like comparisons
on YouTube you could hear the difference
and all that if you are like a trained
musician but for what she's doing if you
think she's a street performer it
doesn't [ __ ] matter
oh hi it seems like she had it before
she became homeless
yeah she did because we're some people
that out but that aren't into call me
can't tell the difference between you
and Bart Baker either true
well he's funny no he does you know Bart
Baker's like quitting you like he quit
YouTube and he's like busy a star shine
are some yeah he's doing [ __ ] China
clashes Ransome [ __ ] on a vice yeah
Jesus that guy's killing day not always
a joke
vice is in the [ __ ] Walmart then
right yeah yeah I was gonna back to
Emily here me I am Bob Baker yeah he was
here once yeah one he was waiting I used
to do his vids we used to do Vince
dealer we did a couple of business guys
we're yeah anyway Emily
so a Grammy nominated music producer
named Joel diamond old
TMZ that he drafted an offer letter for
Emily in hopes of making a huge
classical EDM crossover hit record for
the subway so no and that the first
record will be called paradise and it
will be released on silver-blue records
which is a record label like hey
whatever it takes to get her off the
streets man
yes there have been to go fun needs now
one of them is a currently 61 thousand
six hundred and four dollars and the
other one is thirty three thousand five
hundred fifty eight dollars my favorite
about two violins apparently what did
she actually does that she just gets two
more violet right well back up one in
case again blog yeah what if it's just
the acoustics of the train station that
soak you know everyone sounds good in
the shower yeah what if you pull her out
and then you put her into a vocal booth
and then I don't know she can't perform
she actually said that - she was like I
love singing in the in the subway
because of the vibrations itself but she
said that she's not a trained singer
that she but she wouldn't turn down a
job offer to sing so she's making up
those words what a [ __ ] to say that no
I wouldn't turned down a job I would
dream of dream I'm singing like this and
she's like well I'm not trained singer
and it's like Jesus shattering glass in
here ma'am
and definitely didn't you tell me did
not donate Turco funnyman till now it's
her mentality that got our homeless yep
hear that guys it's her mentality cuz
she's been 10 G's on the [ __ ]
violence yeah just baby habits not a
business all right so you guys lost
everything what is your one but suck
some dick no be sexual what is the one
talent that you could be discovered by
collecting cans oh oh
it's covered I think suck a dick he give
discovers that talent bro I don't think
I have a secret talent that's good
enough to your money that's hard crime
my I'm talent I could be talented in
crime it won't weigh so so someone is
walking with a GoPro when I take that
[ __ ] from their hand there goes our
market that's a good crime
[Music]
[Music]